[Music]
clowns some love them lots eat them but
in the UK it's a serious business this
[Music]
is a responsibility he is for fun as
well to do of course that's Debbie my
name is Debbie and I'm the clown egg
artist she's in charge of the clown egg
registry a collection of every single
clowns face in all of the United Kingdom
tradition of the painting of the eggs
was started first of all as a hobby by
Stan bolt it then became a way of
recording and copywriting clowns face
because every clowns face is different
various different artists then became
the egg artists and I took over six
years ago Debbie's job is to paint onto
an egg the unique makeup of each clown
it's not a physical object that looks
like that character it's so totally
different to having a photograph the
clown egg registry is a collection of
dozens of eggs that serves as an
official list of each individual clown's
personality and look whether the order
comes through from there the clown will
send his application for but along with
certain samples of material and they
send photographs and themself different
angles and I start by sketching the
portrait onto the egg and then gradually
add color with the paint so sometimes
there's actual hair that oh it's like
wall that war-making to hair to put on
it depends on the character but they're
all there to make you laugh
propose again please it's a
responsibility because it is very
important to carry on that tradition
[Music]
the faces are the most important subject
matter in art it's a never-ending source
of material when you put on one of my
masks you become somebody different you
start to embody that character and have
a lot of fun with it
my name is Landon Meyer and I make
disturbingly realistic masks I never
thought I was gonna make a living doing
masks when I was a picture framer loan
officer pizza delivery driver and then I
got laid off I've always been interested
in doing something that's like really
surreal and nightmarish so it was more
or less an experiment that took off I am
the only person out there that's doing
hyper realistic lightness masks I'm kind
of this weird mad scientist down in the
basement I start off getting lots of
reference material the hardest part is
doing the sculpture that can take
anywhere from four days to a year but
once the sculpt is done and I have a
mold it's about a one week process to
make a mask
they are ungodly expensive they ranged
$500 and up and sometimes even high as
$7,500
over the years I've made approximately
25 different designs and I've produced
with my own hands over a thousand masks
what I make I like to consider wearable
art these are super realistic sculptures
you can put over your head and where
people just seem to have this astonished
reaction to masks that's what I love
about them
[Music]
effect through worst areas Sanga do not
know sentence imposed on our campus on
purpose a person by veins or speak of
the knackers
[Music]
also a clinic around estas Patara
circuit printers nurses or spittle and
stratton so election observers hospitals
arsenal familias introduced which
becomes to emulate C&C drink
we ate our streams continual contest
Boneta Centrum
not my personal orifice aims of the
agnostic taka-kun hospital CAPM some
official the boys viviendo cackle sizzle
Tim's solid solution farcical Tomatoes
memorial Keystone's not sue dosed
organisms bhootish causes mess with
Silvia save some spaces anxious to leave
[Music]
soil versus doing Sahaj frequent
conquers Wyatt harvester squeezes my
Liberty dispatch Creon sister Gauri
Turkish Empire is red sky two-to-one
Nastya moose winters emergency
Odysseus's miss Agron maryam nias
a pretty Rock Rockstar Aras improvement
condos hasta pronto valves practice van
honks car no Elvis Pataki important some
sushi van katakana screw father
important prognosis grams are so that
there's no areas cuando intrigue answers
makers with a zester Saitama lagrima the
preserve the
so dodged attempt kriyas if accomplished
and him scenography
the other stomach mush contedner
schwoz'd ignore some school today hours
[Music]
people asked me to stay here for my day
job isn't what you do tedious as a
stop-motion animator you very conscious
of time and of incrementally moving a
three-dimensional object
bit by bit by dead mad God is a
stop-motion film that I've been kind of
making for like the last 30 years
there's nothing stopping me from
continuing doing it you know forever
[Music]
when I was 5 years old in 1955 I saw
King Kong ontology as a stupid kid I was
just enthralled by Hollywood monsters
and that was really the thing that kind
of kindled my appetite
subsequently over the years I have worn
many hats in the motion picture racket
I've been involved with Star Wars the
Robocop series Jurassic Park Starship
Troopers on and on one of the things
that gives me a lot of pleasure is is to
make something but the day job has
certain requirements to it over the
years those requirements have become a
lot more limiting the Mad Dog project
allowed me to just make this more pure
thing that was kind of a form of therapy
for me as an antidote to my day job
it's a combination of live-action and
stop-motion miniature sets in layers
like a collage for lack of a better term
it's a passion project and things keep
getting deeper and darker and honor
there are imaginary cities that are
built out of iron ingots there's like
strange jungles that you go through
there's this huge de stop ik
post-industrial nightmare city and it
just goes on and on and on exactly
anything that I can think of inherent in
it there's a level of surprise that I
think you know for me is very childlike
kind of effect I shoot here at my studio
in Berkeley it's stocked with all kinds
of stuff for all kinds of different
electronic projects woodworking projects
lights cameras so it's a huge toy box
all of the characters in that god are
built by me the process begins with the
articulated skeleton and that's made by
Balan Saket or hinge joints that allow
you to move the characters incrementally
one frame at a time and then I just wrap
lengths of polyurethane foam and build
up the general mass from there I will
take latex skins adhere them what for
everson have paint the thing and then
it's ready to shoot I mean you're
actually shooting a stop-motion scene
you project into the character and
sometimes it can get very complicated
you are always gauging acceleration and
deceleration and weight and mass and
then that kind of leads to but you know
what what would make it better
for me this whole process is more of a
confession I really have no say over
it's just something when I honey I have
to do yeah I've been doing it so long
it's it I breathe I live and breathe in
this world it's all I think about
[Music]